i'm now in front of the
american embassy in kabul
this used to be the heart of the
american effort in afghanistan for 20
years
now everyone is gone and the green zone
of kabul which used to be the nerve
center of the international military
operations and civilian reconstruction
efforts is now an abandoned ghost town
our senior officials also want this to
repair and build good relations with
them again
and for the embassies to reopen
you can see behind me some graffiti the
reminder of the old afghanistan the
african republic that is now gone
and always watch towers
of the international coalition
headquarters that is also left
afghanistan at the end of august
the american embassy as far as we know
has not been penetrated however the odds
of american humans returning to kabul
anytime soon are quite low the us has
not recognized the taliban government as
the legitimate rules of afghanistan and
neither has any other country so far
though several others such as china
russia or qatar or pakistan do maintain
embassies in the city and do engage in
contacts with the detail about
authorities